[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAX SALTONSTALL: My
name is Max Saltonstall.
And I am in need of a new couch.
But finding a new couch
is not actually that easy,
especially when I
don't really want to go
into a whole bunch of stores.
If only there is some way
that I could virtually
see a whole lot of
different couch options.
Hm, I know a guy who works
at a company that I think
can help us.
I'm here with
Barry from Marxent.
Barry, thanks for
joining me today.
Can you tell me a little bit
about what you and Marxent do?
BARRY BESECKER: Hi, Max.
I'm the CTO and
Cofounder of Marxent.
And we provide content
management systems
for 3D products as
well as applications
for ecommerce experiences
for retailers and brands,
specifically products
for the home.
MAX SALTONSTALL: So
finding a new couch,
because I need a new couch, how
can Marxent help me do that?
BARRY BESECKER: So
Marxent provides
room-planning applications and
augmented reality applications
and web AR experiences that let
consumers come in and design
and layout a new floor
plan for their kitchen,
for their bedroom, dining
room, or living room.
And they take 3D
products that are
the actual products that
they can buy from a retailer
or from a manufacturer.
And they can arrange those
products in the space.
They can try out
different styles.
They can switch their wall
paint, their flooring,
and their lighting.
And they can really design
their future living space.
And then when they're done, they
can add all those items to cart
and check out on a retailer
or a manufacturer's website.
So that's what we do is bring
those room planning and AR
experiences to
life for the home.
MAX SALTONSTALL: That's awesome.
So that's going to be really
helpful when I can't just
go to a whole bunch
of furniture stores,
but I want to know
what my options are.
Can you walk me through
what is the life of, say,
one couch as it goes from
an idea in some furniture
designer's mind to eventually
landing in my living room?
Where do we start?
BARRY BESECKER: So it all starts
with a content order, where
we'll work with a
client who, let's say,
wants to put 3,000 couches with
different fabrics, leathers,
different wood
finishes, whatever
it happens to be into their
room-planning application.
So they'll work
with us to identify
what those SKUs are going
to be and provide us
reference materials.
Sometimes that's a CAD
engineering drawings.
Sometimes it's high-poly
assets that they've used
for a photography replacement.
Sometimes it's just photos.
And sometimes it's just a link
to their PDP on their website.
We'll take those assets.
And then we'll go through
a planning exercise.
Now, a planning
exercise will identify
with a unique set
of assets that we
need to create to
accomplish that order.
One of the things
about the home space
is a lot of the
products in a room can
share similar materials, can
share similar subcomponents.
For instance, if you think about
a sofa, you're buying the sofa.
You have the cushions.
You have the feet on the sofa.
You have pillows
that may be shared
across the other items in
the room, like a love seat,
for instance, that's styled
in the same collection.
So we'll identify
even subcomponents
of those products that can
be built once or designed
once and then reused
multiple times,
which really brings
down the cost
and effort around maintenance
or when changes come in
for that order.
So once that planning
exercise is complete,
we'll go through
a routing exercise
through our CMS application.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Very cool.
So in the very
beginning, retailer says,
here's my 3,000 couches.
Luckily, I only need one couch,
but you might need 3,000.
Where does that come to?
What does it sit in
when you absorb that?
BARRY BESECKER: So the
back end of our CMS
is a custom relational database
that runs on Cloud SQL.
And then for the file assets,
textures, images, the reference
material, 3D meshes--
all of those are stored
in Cloud Storage.
And so the custom
application is front
ended by an Angular application
that runs on Firebase.
So all the artists, the
planners, the analytics,
all of those users use that
3D workflow application
to manage the entire process,
really, from beginning to end.
And then once it's published,
those assets end up on a CDN.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Great.
So assets come in.
Artists might be making
new textures or new models.
They're all being
listed in the database,
and that's keeping track of
how they relate to each other.
This is a type of wood, or
this is a type of linen.
And then at some point, they
need to be combined, right?
You need to know that my
couch needs to be Naugahyde
because that's very important.
So how are you doing that
combination ahead of time?
Because I'm assuming you don't
want to do it right on demand
when I'm trying to put that
couch in my living room.
BARRY BESECKER: Absolutely.
And that's really one
of the big lessons
we learned early
on as our session
started to scale that
this relational database
system that we
built for building
these individual assets
is great for management,
great for maintenance,
great for reusability,
and really reduces the effort
around that content creation
lifecycle.
When it comes to
consumption, it's
really not a great environment
to pull all those assets
on demand.
We even found that
in many cases,
pulling an individual product
because of all the reuse
could end up with 50 different
queries that need to be run,
which could really put a large
load on a content management
system.
So we developed is a
compile-time set of features
that would notice whenever
an artist would change
one individual
component of a product,
notifying all the products
that would be affected
by that individual change.
And then really,
at compile time,
just like you have nightly job
services for a DevOps team,
would compile and
basically build
a runtime version of that
product that can then
be published to CDN at scale.
What's nice about that is then
when the end application wants
to consume that 3D product, it
just downloads that manifest
and then pulls all
the individual assets
that needs to render that
without really ever affecting
the core content
management operation.
MAX SALTONSTALL: It's cool.
So does that mean
that you're generating
new assets, new composite assets
in the Cloud Storage buckets,
tracking the relationship
between the core pieces
and the composites
in your database,
and then publishing the
finished composites to the CDN
so that they can be
easily pulled down
to my laptop or my phone?
BARRY BESECKER: That's right.
And we've seen big benefits
with that approach.
Really, our servers or our
applications never go down.
You're taking advantage
of a lot of cached data
that is deployed to CDN.
We even take some of the
indexes around product lists
and the configuration
of our applications
to deploy those via
SQLite so that those
can be downloaded as
little mini databases
when the application starts up.
So we can reduce the
chattiness back and forth
through web services
as the user is
experiencing the application.
So really, in many
of these cases,
once they start
the application up,
until they're ready to
save their end room layout,
they could run in a
completely offline way.
And so a lot of the
information can be cached,
and we wait until changes
happen to redownload it.
So users can come in and
out of the application
if new content has
been published.
They're running pretty much
locally in the browser cache.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
That sounds like it's
going to make performance for
me, the consumer, a lot better
but also reduce
the amount that you
have to send over the network.
BARRY BESECKER: Absolutely.
And that's really
what it's about
is kind of pleasing
these two different users
of this platform.
It's around letting the artists
produce the most amount of 3D
products with the
least number of assets
and then be able to
respond to changes that
come in from the client or from
the project team as they're
deploying a new application.
But at the same time,
pleasing the end consumer,
creating as fast
as downloads as we
can with a minimum
number of assets.
And so we can create the best
quality rendering experience
on the front end for the amount
of assets that we're using.
MAX SALTONSTALL: And in
retail, if you're too slow,
someone is going to wander away.
But also if your
systems go down,
that downtime is lost money for
all of your retailer clients.
So how do you make
sure that your back end
is reliable enough to keep them
still selling all the time?
BARRY BESECKER: It's really
about isolating that production
environment and consumption
environment from the creation
environment where all
the assets are built.
And by keeping those
separate, we don't really have
to worry about downtime at all.
When new content
batches go out, they
can be tested through, really,
an A/B testing deployment
that we've implemented.
And so we never really
worry about downtime
when it comes to
consuming the assets
or using the end applications.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Awesome.
It sounds like a pretty
sophisticated system
that's mostly invisible
to me is I just
get to enjoy virtual couches all
over, filling my living room up
to the ceiling.
BARRY BESECKER: That's the hope.
It's been about 10 years in
building this environment
and kind of solving all the
different problems that we've
seen along the way with
making the process more
efficient for creation
and then also making
the process highly optimized
for consumption as well.
MAX SALTONSTALL: That's awesome.
Thank you, Barry, for
coming on and for telling us
this story about how these
virtual sofas can travel
through that entire
Cloud infrastructure
to end up in my
virtual and hopefully,
eventually, my
physical living room.
I really appreciate it.
BARRY BESECKER: Thanks, Max.
It's been great.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Wow.
So now I get how all those
virtual couches ended up all
over my living room.
Oh, I guess I have
to pick one now, huh?
Well, I'm really
glad that Barry was
able to explain how
Marxent is using
all these different
pieces of Google Cloud
to power this super cool
retail experience from home.
If you want to learn more
about what they've done
and what many others have
done on Google Cloud,
click on the link below to see
the rest of "Architecting Cloud
Solutions."
Thanks for watching.